estábamos hablando hace un momento de
las sanciones son muchos temas eh
alrededor del impacto económico que ha
tenido esta guerra en Ucrania mencionada
justamente Jorge las sanciones y también
lo hacía nuestro corresponsal Xavier
collage Cuál es el impacto real de estas
sanciones en territorio ruso
Pues en general Yo diría que Rocío
sufrió menos que el resto del mundo de
las sanciones y es sorprendente Porque
primero en tiempos de guerra el gobierno
ruso está dispuesto de dictar a su
pueblo así son las condiciones ahora y
también crisis alimentaria energética
eso no son
productos de lujo eso es algo que
vulnera inmediatamente a una población
un un país como gana en África que está
tan dependiendo de alimentos de Ucrania
no puede vivir ni cuatro semanas sin
Esto entonces el impacto de las de las
sanciones y las respuestas rusas en esto
no son bastante balanceados verdad es
sorprendente porque se pensaba antes que
serían mucho más fuertes y
forzarían a Rusia de cambiar su
estrategia pero hasta ahora no se ha
visto mar los sancionados fueron
oligarcas y funcionarios rusa fue
expulsado del sistema bancario Swift y
sólo fue hasta finales del año pasado
que empezaron a sancionar los
hidrocarburos A qué se debió esta
decisión
pues es Claro si tú estás dependiendo y
rectángulos no estás dispuesto de muy
fácilmente
abandonarlos Entonces es eso va a causar
mucho ruido también por las fricciones
entre Estados Unidos y ropa adentro
especialmente Alemania adentro de la de
la otan sabemos que con esta este tuvo
en el Báltico ha causado muchos
problemas que los gringos Los Americanos
dijeron unos días antes de la guerra si
ellos invadieron vamos a bombardear este
este tubo eso es lo que pasó entonces
esos son son cosas que es muy difícil
porque obviamente Alemania es un Francia
también es un país industrializado y es
como alimentos para África lo mismo es
energía para países industriales ellos
no pueden decir pues vivimos un año sin
energía y vamos a ver qué esto no no por
eso yo digo Bueno raro o ropa también
este estas medidas Marcos el año pasado
el pib ruso se contrajo dos coma cinco
por ciento mucho menos de los que se
esperaba que le ha permitido a Rusia
mantenerse a pesar de estas sanciones
Pues sí como halarlo verdad nosotros no
compramos nuestros combustibles ahora
directamente en Rose sino por desviar de
India India gana mucha plata con esto si
hay demanda siempre hay oferta y sube el
precio eso es una ley económica y
también se busca otras fuentes pero
Rusia No yo no creo que Rusia va a
sucumbir a estos a estas estas
sanciones no parece